joining us now he is the editorinchief
the founder investigative reporter
justthenews.com uh as we check in with
John Solomon tonight John you have more
than any reporter in this country been
following this story and have broken
pretty much by yourself every big aspect
of this story I want to go through this
slowly because I think there's so many
parts of this that people don't know
about and that people have missed let's
first go to the tax charges now wasn't
it David Weiss that was contradicted by
the whistleblowers didn't David Weiss
originally plan not to bring any charges
and only as a result of the
Whistleblower testimony did he then
bring it to another level and that
became the sweetheart deal that blew
apart in open court because of a
Delaware
judge yeah listen first off this uh
indictment tonight affirms every fact
that the whistleblowers Gary shapley and
Joe Ziggler gave they were they've been
tormented by some in the media and
certainly by Hunter Biden's Defenders
their truthfulness is 100% confirmed in
this indictment tonight and they changed
the course of history uh David Weiss's
team was content to give Hunter Biden a
small uh a small uh uh misdemeanor plea
deal for Hunter Biden now he's facing
three felonies nine charges 17 years in
prison they changed the course of
history also tonight Joe Biden has a
very B bad mark on his record now just
think about this this indictment
portrays Hunter Biden as a
quintessential tax cheat a guy who'd
rather spend money on sex clubs than pay
his taxes a guy who made millions in
foreign money but wouldn't pay his taxes
even when he filed his own taxes from
time to time he would cheat even when he
filed his taxes uh the indictment
alleges there's a very important fact
here back in 2019 I reported and I was
ridiculed for reporting that Ukrainian
prosecut wanted to tell the United
States government that Hunter Biden did
not pay taxes on some of his brisma
income tonight David Weiss's indictment
through the grand jury affirmed by the
grand jury confirms Hunter Biden did not
pay taxes on the money he earned from
barisma Holdings in 2014 just like the
Ukrainian authorities tried to tell the
United States government in 2019 but
they were turned away uh this is a
devastating indictment for a president
his own son is portrayed as a tax sheet
this is a president that time and again
has told us he wants to crack down on
tax cheats he wants to uh hire 89,000
more uh IRS agents in this case here his
own son is the poster child for what a
tax cheat looks like at least in this
indictment you know John let me ask you
this I want to go back because the years
the barisma years and this is where
almost from the very beginning uh this
tipped everybody off because it was so
unusual so let me just focus in on that
one deal in particular am I wrong or or
right on the issue in October of
2015 uh didn't it become official Obama
administration policy uh to give a
billion dollars in loan guarantees to
Ukraine and that was after an inter
agency investigation and they decided
enough progress on the issue of
corruption in Ukraine warranted the
billion in loan guarantees that happened
in October of 2015 is that correct you
report that's right there were a series
of Rec September and October 15 and
consecutive months the treasury
Department justice department State
Department agreed together that Ukraine
and its prosecutor General's office had
made enough progress on uh corruption
reforms it deserved a billion dollars in
new loan guarantees and by the way
Europe also concurred with that
opinion let me ask you this John because
then in December of 2015 this is the
same year we're talking about uh Hunter
is with barice M Executives this is at
the time and correct me if I'm wrong
this is at the time they needed DC help
or maybe that they needed the Biden
brand if you wanted to use Devon
Archer's analogy and at that time they
were in Dubai Hunter was in Dubai and
barisma Executives were in Dubai and
they had a phone call with Joe Biden uh
five days later I believe Joe Biden went
to Ukraine that's when Joe Biden was
bragging about the issue uh that in fact
he said fire the prosecutor you got six
hours uh or you're not getting the money
okay he fires the prosecutor as a result
of that firing Ukraine Got the loan
guarantee which was already official
Obama administration policy uh and
Hunter Biden who admits he had no
experience on Good Morning America in
oil gas energy or coal uh he continued
to get paid millions of dollars for a
job he clearly was not qualified for at
a time where they're admitting that he
was addicted to drugs and alcohol is
that the proper timeline on
that that is exactly the timeline in
October uh bisma started to get worried
that the uh Ukrainian prosecutors are
ramp ing up their investigation Hunter
Biden starts talking to people around
Joe Biden one of Joe Biden's advisers
talks to Joe Biden about it the career
people are recommending give Ukraine the
money they've done enough do Joe Biden
according to the Washington Post now the
Washington Post is changing story they
now say that Joe Biden called an audible
you know what an audible is a change in
play at a football game he called an
audible and decided he was going to
withhold the billion dollars en Force
the firing of the very prosecutor that
was making barisma Panic Hunter Biden's
company was panicked and they fire
Victor shoken uh that is exactly what I
reported in 2019 and today the evidence
validates that uh timeline let me go
back so then how is it that that uh
David Weiss investigating this how did
he let the statute of limitations pass
on the issue of taxes involving the
bishma years because we're talking about
millions of dollars there was that not
the timeline well those years the that
the statute of limitations passed there
because that would have been highly
unusual because they could have gone to
Hunter Biden's Attorneys at the time and
said we're extending this or we're going
to charge you wouldn't that be the
normal
practice yes and nor they do what's
called a tolling agreement which extends
the statute you keep negotiating maybe
you get a deal but you preserve the
government's ability to bring the
charges that tolling agreement according
to the whistleblowers was allowed to
expire in the fall of 2022 meaning the
$400,000 in income that Hunter Biden to
David Weiss confirms this today confirms
the whistleblowers $400,000 in income
that Hunter Biden got from barisma in
2014 could no longer be charged as a
felony tax evasion case today they
mention it in the narrative but they
can't charge him with it because of the
fact that they allowed the statute of
limitations to go and I think all of
this would have been swept under the rug
based on all the reporting I've done
with FBI and IRS and other officials
this would have all been swept under the
rug if Gary shapley and Joseph ziger
didn't come forward and blow the whistle
to Congress all right let me ask you
this next question question here Joe
Biden has said over and over again he
said it as a candidate he said it as a
president he said it this week that he
never once talked to his brother uh or
his son or anybody for that matter about
their foreign business dealings now we
know that's not true John Solomon we
know because Devon Archer told us it's
not true and he himself as a partner
knew of at least 20 occasions when Joe
got on the phone with Hunter their Farm
business partners and then of course we
have uh photo evidence of Joe Biden
meeting with Elena batarina that's the
Russian oligarch former first lady of
Moscow $3.5 million deal that they did
with her later leading to her investing
I believe over a hundred million in a
real estate venture with them uh but Joe
Biden met with her at the Cafe Milano
didn't he and he met with other foreign
business partners at the Cafe Milano
didn't he he did and he met with one in
the uh Naval Observatory the official
vice president residence when he was
vice president a guy connected to
Kazakhstan uh Joe Biden is simply not
telling the truth when he said those are
lies the only lies are his response to
the the evidence is overwhelming that he
did meet that he did get some money from
his Senate remember he lied and said my
family never got money from China today
David Weiss documents millions of
dollars coming from China to his family
and tomorrow morning we're going to
provide some new evidence showing that
Joe Biden is right in the middle of this
scheme with the help of Senator Ron
Johnson we're going to be able to reveal
tomorrow there are six um suspicious
activity reports that came in from banks
that were flagging two possible criminal
activities human trafficking and money
laundering that list Joe Biden's
Delaware residence as the source and
origin or origination of the financial
transactions that result in their
concern Joe Biden's house was sort of a
crime scene for these Banks reporting
possible money laundering and human
trafficking his home the home that he
allowed his son to stay in for some time
it's listed six in six Banks $12 million
of transactions in these six suspicious
activity reports it's the first time we
knew that Joe Biden's house is in the
middle of what banks thought were money
laundering and human trafficking schemes
that's going to come out tomorrow
morning well unbelievable and your
reporting has been dead on accurate I
will tell you there also is this issue
of David Weiss contradicting himself in
separate letters I believe to one
Senator one Congressman uh and also the
com by merri Garland didn't Merrick
Garland testify before Congress that
David Weiss had the authority to charge
in other jurisdictions that was what
David Weiss was telling the
whistleblowers that he did not have he
did not have the authority to charge in
other jurisdictions but he said
something else to to one branch of
Congress and and something else to a
different branch correct what the house
and the Senate not a you know different
houses there's a lot to sort out here
but other Witnesses have affirmed The
Whistleblower story and rebuked both the
accounts of Meritt Garland and David
Weiss David Weiss I think now has given
a more complete account when he finally
sat down with Jim Jordan and he
acknowledged listen I got turned down by
the Biden appointees in Washington in
California I then let the statute of
limitations go I couldn't even do things
without getting the approval of the tax
division that was run by Joe Biden's
appointees so Weiss has gotten the story
right now his story matches the
whistleblowers it matches the IRS and
FBI supervisors and others at Jim Jordan
and James comr have interviewed but
early on there was a lot of fast and
loose the only people that turned out to
be consistently accurate the IRS
whistleblowers and by the way you have
been following the story of Kevin Morris
who apparently made a loan of $4.9
million but as part of that didn't you
discover that one of the reasons he
thought it was important to help Hunter
out financially uh was because the issue
of of taxes would be front and center in
the 2020 presidential race
yes he actually writes an email saying
that there's going to be political and
personal Peril for Hunter Biden if he
doesn't start paying his taxes this
occurs right in 2020 right after he
meets Hunter Biden at a Joe Biden
fundraiser those emails came out
yesterday Kevin Morris is mentioned as
an unnamed person here the uh David
Weiss confirms that uh Kevin Morris was
starting to pay it's an unnamed person
but we know him to be Kevin Morris
started to pay hun Biden's bills
including his rent and his tax bills
starting in the 2020 time frame so that
story has now been affirmed too there's
a lot to dig in in any other presidency
if a donor came in and started giving
millions of dollars to the president's
son or children or wife or brother it
would be a big Scandal most of the media
have tried to ignore this over the last
few weeks but David Weiss puts it front
and center tonight in this indictment is
Joe Biden really the tip of the spear
here in other words we wouldn't be
talking about any of this would we if
Joe Biden wasn't the brand if Joe Biden
didn't lie to the American people
repeatedly why lie if you're not
involved right why lie if you did
nothing wrong but Joe Biden lied to the
country repeatedly is lying again even
this week on this very issue is it true
that that the center of all of this is
the president of the United States it
involves let's see 150 some odd uh
suspicious activity reports uh all of
these shell corporations all of these
Biden family members including
grandchildren that are being paid
millions of dollars from some of our top
geopolitical foes uh being paid into
this family no evidence of any services
that we can find rendered in exchange
for that money is that where we are now
tonight John last question we are and
listen uh uh Hunter Biden himself
admitted this in an interview two years
ago a lot of things came his way solely
because of his last name yes that's why
he got hired yes that's why Millions
came into the family and they lied about
it in 2019 and 20 certainly Joe Biden
did and today the American public have a
much clearer example of a grift scream
scheme that the Biden ran that involve
tax evasion now and also money
laundering concerns at the banks and Joe
Biden's home is in the middle of it
that's going to be the big thing
tomorrow Joe Biden aided and Abed this
uh uh scheme for a long time his family
got rich off it now the last remaining
question for James comr and Jim Jordan
how much did Joe Biden personally
benefit from it that I think the
impeachment inquiry will ultimately be
able to answer yeah I wonder now if he
will use this as an excuse uh not to
appear before James Comer's committee uh
we'll watch that in the days to come as
well John Solomon thank you